all right hello everybody
okay so i guess we are live we are
starting
and so um
there are a lot of stuff there's a lot
of stuff going on this month so many
things so i have a few announcements i
was in florida
earlier this month it was um
it was pretty amazing you know there
there's let's say people are covered um
or less crazy about kobet and so it was
just nice to be with people without
masks in the church you know just
celebrating and uh
it was just wonderful and uh i spoke to
the diocese the oca diocese of the south
and uh so there was i don't know a
hundred priests i don't forget how many
a lot of priests and two bishops so it's
pretty um it was pretty exciting to be
able to participate with that uh the
archbishop of the um
of the of the south is uh
is alexander uh glitzin and so he is
like a great scholar on the
on the dionysus the areopagite you know
and the divine names so it's very
intimidating to speak in front of him
but i felt like we it felt like it went
pretty well we even had like a q a
together like kind of a q a chat and i
thought it went well
so i might post at least one of those
talks
um
in the next few weeks but i have a lot
of backlog i did so many interviews in
the when i finished my kovid i was just
like i just needed to do things so i
just did all these interviews i've got i
think like five or six that are in the
in the waiting list you know then we
just need to put them out and so one of
the big things that's happening is i've
decided that by
october 31st
all of the podcast versions of these
videos so as you as i hope you know all
of these videos are put out as podcasts
on your favorite podcast
platform
all of these by the end of october will
be up to date which means that hopefully
starting in november when a video comes
out the podcast will come out at the
same time or very
very shortly after like just maybe the
day after or something like that and so
um so yeah so i'm looking forward to to
that because i know a lot of people have
complained that they see the video come
out but they want to listen in their car
they want to listen to work or whatever
but they can't because
because uh because they don't you know
they they don't want to stream video in
their car so uh i get it so hopefully
that will all be fixed but the biggest
thing happening this month is october
31st halloween is the beginning of the
god's dog crowdfunding the graphic novel
all of it is done there only there's
only a little bit of coloring and a
little bit of inking left to do but the
entire first volume of the story is
finished
and uh and so we've set up a
indiegogo crowdfunding campaign all you
need to do is go to godsdog.com so it's
just god's dog straight out dot com and
uh or or find it on indiegogo and uh
october 31st i'm really hoping that
people if you want to to um
if you want to support this if you want
to get involved in the crowdfunding try
to do it
right away like on october 31st or the
day after because the more impact we
have the more indiegogo is going to
notice and also the more other people
are going to notice what's going on
um i'm really
and i have a lot of hope for this
crowdfunding i don't know
i know exactly how it's going to go i
don't know exactly what that means but
um
to me this is like a new beginning in a
certain way it's like i'm trying to put
something out in the world which
not only explains my vision of
storytelling but really puts it in
practice and as you know materia and i
worked on this for many years together
just refining the story kind of uh
bringing it together and uh and so we're
really excited to put it out there we've
gotten some great reviews already from
from people uh like paul kingsnorth you
know greg hurwitz and other people
several people have read it and we've
gotten some great feedback
from the the graphic novel so so yeah so
check it out
godsdog.com you can already
sign up for uh like a like an email list
so that when the uh crowdfunding starts
you will get all the details and you'll
you'll you'll be right on the
on the cusp of that so that is
to me that's the biggest thing going on
i've been spending a lot of time on that
writing
um
press releases uh you know uh there's a
good friend of mine renu ghani who's
helping me to set up facebook ads and to
do all the stuff that i don't know how
to do and one of the things we might be
doing as well is uh is an nft version
of the graphic novel so but that's
something that i need to get the pulse
from people out there and so if an nft
version
of of god's dog is something that you'd
be interested in please find a way to
leave a comment in the youtube or
something to kind of make a little bit
of noise so i know whether or not it's
worth it i have an idea in the nfts to
have some
to have a few nfts that are that are
quite rare and will include you know
will link to basically own a pdf file
that uh that will have a few secrets
that other people won't have access to a
few ciphers that of the stuff that is in
that is in god's dog and then the person
who owns it can do whatever they want
with it they can decide to uh
they can decide to uh to uh to share it
or to keep it for themselves but uh
anyway so that's one of the things i'm
thinking of so already seeing in the
chat that people are saying don't do
nfts and so all right we have one voice
there let's see
let's see what other voices are coming
uh another thing happening is you know
with the youtube pressure there's a lot
of pressure a lot of channels are being
deleted
and uh right at the moment where i
finally got my 100 000 subscriber button
that they're going to send me which you
know that's cool that's i'm happy that
they're going to send me the 100 000
subscriber button but i'm also being
very i'm a little wary about what's
happening and so um i've also set up on
uh
on rothkin which is a
which is a platform that uses crypto as
it's
as its structure uh jay dyer is already
there and he's the only person i know
there but there's a sam tripoli is there
and a few other people that i don't know
about
um and so all the
all of my videos are now being uploaded
up to rofkin and what i'm going to do is
for people who subscribe
to uh to me on on rothkin people that
are subscribed to rothkin will also have
access
to the uh the the patreon only video so
it's a way to think about a transition
i'm gonna see what it does to see how it
how it works and so it might be a way
for people to to support what i'm doing
but also have access
to um to another platform and so that's
something that i'm going to offer
and so all right so enough about me and
about what's going on with me there's a
lot of other things the things that are
going on uh we'll start with the
questions now this month and from now on
i've changed the mode of the q a a
little bit
which is that as you might have noticed
the q and a's are very long long and
unwieldy they just become extremely at
some point at the end of it you know i
start telling people that they shouldn't
ask the questions they're asking which
is not a good sign as to how tired i
become at the end of them um
and so what we're gonna do is first of
all i'm not gonna open the super chats
anymore so there'll be no super chats
because it's that's also too chaotic and
you know um we'll also have moderators
go through the questions that are asked
on the different support platforms so
the way i do it now is because there's
just too many questions so the way i do
it is for people that support me for 10
or more they can ask questions on the
different platforms that they're using
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to select about 50 questions from
all the questions that are asked the the
selection will be done
based on whether or not i've answered
these questions many times uh if the
question is a little unclear or
sometimes if the person makes very very
long statement before the question so
try to be concise in your questions uh
try to to ask things that haven't been
asked before that's hard to know
obviously for everybody um and so uh so
yeah so uh so let's do it
let's go
and so i will start with the the website
the paypal
website questions
all right so douglas matthew asked not
sure if you're familiar with the
la palma volcano eruption but there is a
belief out there that this could you
might say cast half the mountain this
island
into the sea and cause a devastating
tsunami across the atlantic can you talk
about the symbolism of volcanoes and how
that symbolism might relate to
the symbolism of the flood
and so
so the symbolism of the volcano is
different i think i see
the symbolism of the volcano i see
closer to something like the destruction
of
of sodom and gomorrah
and the
the so the difference between the flood
destroyed by water and destroyed by fire
you know it's interesting that
um
the flood is like something which starts
above and then comes down
you know on the on the the waters and
also it comes out of the earth often in
the story especially in the story of the
biblical flood like water coming out of
the ground
uh and uh and flooding the world
uh and a volcano is a mountain so it's
like it's something about fire and light
kind of uh
destroying the world
that's the best way i understand it you
know
like judgment like a kind of like a
fiery judgment which comes which kind of
comes down the mountain onto the people
so that's the best way i understand that
so eric salander asked i would like to
know the link between creation and
singing
token creates his world through music
and also in the finnish
calibala singing has a big role to play
not only in creation of the world but
also in magical battles and spells
hope to talk to you soon
and so um
the idea of of the why singing appears
in creation stories not so much the um
the biblical one but in other cultures
and like you said in token it has to do
with pattern it's patterned speaking so
there are all these different legends
right there legends will say things like
um
that that uh adam and eve in the garden
used to
um
used to speak in verse let's say they
used to speak in poetry and then
as they left the as they left the sacred
space then they
they cease to speak in poetry and so the
idea that poetry
is you know poet like
songs also have a poetic way of saying
and a poetic way of of writing uh in uh
with with rhyme or with meter you know
with different structures and so the
idea it's like it's ordered speaking
right ordered speaking ordered sounds so
i think that that's what that's what
it's related to you know this notion
that for example that the heavenly
spheres make sounds
and that those sounds
are like a kind of hidden symphony like
a hidden musical piece a hidden pattern
that only certain people are are allowed
to uh intuit and so i think that it's
all related to that it's all related to
patterned
pattern speaking compared to
kind of chaotic uh you know informal
speaking so think about it the
difference between liturgy and everyday
life where you know liturgy is more
patterned more structured and reveals
more of how the world is formed uh
whereas it's still there in everyday
life but it not so much right it's or
it's harder to see in everyday life
so i think that's what it is
so
james mclaughlin says pre-modern
obsession with damnation i'm reading the
forge of christendom by tom holland
premodern catholics were obsessed with
damnation in a way that i would think
would seem extreme
even to a modern evangelical what is a
good thing is it necessarily part of the
premodern view were the orthodox
different and so
um
i think it's important to be to have
let's say the memory of death is
probably the best way to think about it
to be aware of your death and aware of
your death in many ways aware of your
death of course in terms of your
physical death your right uh but also
aware of your death
in the sense of the place where you
break down you know and that has to do
with
also
the the the final result of that which
is which is the lake of fire let's say
or damnation
and so i think it's good to be aware of
that because what it does is it also it
places your actions in comparison to
the ultimate consequences of them and so
it reminds you of your
you know it reminds you
[Music]
to keep yourself in check right but i
think it could go too far and that is
for sure especially like with the
there's a kind of mat there's a kind of
madness in the over calculating of this
stuff especially like in the calculation
of all the years in purgatory and like
so many years for so many sins in
purgatory and so many this and that and
this and that and
there's a little bit of um
there's a little bit of of exaggeration
in that but um
so so yeah it could go it could go too
far like there is i've said this before
like there is in christianity a sense in
which all things
have their destiny in god and that all
things are meant to
move into god and become part of god's
life and that is balanced out with
another tradition which is something
more like
you know if you don't follow the the
thin you know the uh
the straight path which is thin like a
wire and you have to walk on this wire a
sense in which it's difficult and you
need to sacrifice everything and you
need to
to focus and so those two kind of exist
exist together in a kind of tension uh
and so when you see that obsession with
with damnation
i think you're seeing one side of the of
the coin
so
so david flores says can you elaborate
on the symbolism of hornets particularly
in the context of exodus 23 28 and i
will send hornets before thee
which shall drive out the hivites the
canaanites and the hittites from before
thee
ah that's interesting i've never really
thought about that like i never thought
about the symbolism of hornets in that
context
um
i don't think i'd i think i would be
feel ill at ease to answer that question
i would have to think about it more
um it's a good question it's a good it's
a good good thinking i'm sure my tier
would have a much better answer to this
um
all right jay grubb asks what is the
symbolism of the man who was stoned for
picking up sticks on the sabbath numbers
15 32 36
the passage follows one which walks
about the difference which talks about
the difference between inadvertently
breaking and deliberately breaking the
law so i can understand that aspect
however is there anything going on
beyond that
um
i mean there is a little bit of
interesting there's an interesting thing
in the idea of picking up uh sticks or
picking up trees right and so it's as if
like on the day of the sabbath you don't
engage with with uh patterns you don't
engage with trees you don't engage with
with uh stable things right it's a it's
a day of rest and so picking up sticks
or picking up wood
you're right you have to understand that
in in the old world when they would just
say something like wood it would mean
everything from trees
trees uh to branches right um and so
that that so it has something to do with
that that the day of sabbath is the day
without
um
is the day without without uh pattern
it's like the day of rest so that's the
best way i can understand that i mean in
terms of the consequence it's also about
you know the um
you know how can i say this like
rigor right there's an aspect of
tradition which is that of rigor and so
sometimes there are some stories which
emphasize rigor and they can be a bit
ruthless and terrifying when you think
of it's like yeah you did this here's
the consequence
um
so timothy asperslaw asked hey jonathan
what are your takeaways from
mythologies read the book but it didn't
seem very relevant to me how should i
approach this
it's interesting because i say that i
read it and it's like i don't actually
not even necessarily
suggesting people read it to get the the
type of insight i got because i got for
me what it was it was like a weird it's
kind of like how mature talks about the
double inversion thing that's what was
going on for me
before i realized that what was
happening is that
is describing patterns of behavior in
society as repeating mythological and
religious themes and he does it to
criticize them right he's saying look at
these social patterns how they're just
repeating you know these mythological um
his mythological tropes and his his
background is like a marxist
a background a materialist marks his
background he's doing it to destroy them
he's doing that to expose them so that
we can get rid of meaning and live in a
purely kind of materialistic
uh world but what it ended up doing for
me was the opposite was to see the
patterns and to see
how actually what he was criticizing i
found very interesting because i could
see how it was manifesting these
religious patterns and the conclusions
to which to which i came was that
ultimately it flipped to the other side
where it was like okay you're right you
see these patterns in all these social
structures but you're right to think
that that to criticize them and to want
to get rid of them because
there is no materialism like there is no
neutral world um and so that's how what
i got from that book so you don't have
to read it it's not i don't think i
think there are way better way
more important and more interesting
things to read besides that book
if only to understand the way in which
marxists uh perceive
how me how um
meaning itself is almost is almost evil
you know because it's an imposition of a
pattern from above like an imposition of
meaning from above
all right so tracy becky asks
can you comment on the symbolism of
being pierced in the bible from the
thorns outside the garden of eden to the
bodies of the serpent endured by the
children of israel in the wilderness the
nails
spear and crown
of thorns at the crucifixion is our
current persecution involving needles
part of a pattern
so
so i i think i am
so i think that this is a very profound
symbolism that you've stumbled onto and
it's one which is going to be very
difficult to understand because it
actually it's one of those types of
symbolism
kind of like the video i did on the mark
of kane which is that in the symbolism
is contained something like the
two opposites which are difficult to um
which are difficult to intuit at the
same time
and so
you can understand being pierced
as a form of insufficiency of yourself
right and so you are
pierced from the outside
and so in that that's what the
especially the the thorns as the result
of the fall is which is that
you are
penetrated
by all these things from the outside
okay that you that is so this so you are
you're pierced by all these points uh
and it it and you're leaking right so
because of that you're basically leaking
you're not self-contained okay
uh and so that
has to do with that
um
the bites of the vipers has more to do
with the idea of once again being
pierced from the outside but almost like
in a giving way where the thorns pierce
you in a way that you leak
and the vipers pierces you in a way that
gives you that and poisons you makes you
gives you like a bad uh
makes you subject to like a bad a bad
principality a bad pattern you know
and uh
and so
so it can almost seem like the opposite
of the other one but then in terms of
the crucifixion it's even it's even
another aspect
which is that
in the in the terms of the crucifixion
it has to do with the lamb which is
sacrificed at you know before the
foundation of the world that is
in order for the world so it's it's i'm
going to use i'm actually going to use
this symbolism which people are going to
find is weird but there's actually you
know in from um
from other cultures but in like hindu
mythology there's study of the cosmic
egg right or of the of the first form
which is completely close and completely
perfect
and so there's a sense in which in order
for that to become a world
like a realized world
it has to be
pierced
there has to be some
thing done to it
or some it has to concede something
right in order for the world to then
exist and so now when christ is pierced
it's it's out of his wounds
come creation creation actually leak out
of his wounds and so it has to do with
this idea of of piercing the cosmic
original sphere or the original egg this
kind of pristine
uh world that doesn't have any
variety or multiplicity yet and so it
has to be kind of poked at in order for
everything to come out and so you can
understand it also then as christ giving
himself
right so the divine logos pouring
himself out into creation but also
creation basically is the pouring out so
he creation is emanating from him
in its multiplicity through the through
the sacrifice um
and so sorry because i know that sounded
like
madness to many people
that sounded like total madness but
sorry you just tripped on a on a very
very uh intense symbolism and so if i if
you want me to make it even trippier for
you uh
there's a man in which all of those
are contained also there's a man which
all of these different aspects of being
pierced
are different elements of us of one
symbolism which
which is impossible to
to to talk about which can only be
grasped through a kind of intuition so
anyways
yeah so i'm oh and so does it have to do
with what's going on now yeah it has
it does have to do with that it does
have to do with in our case it has to do
with something like
receiving authority
it's a mixture it's a weird mixture it's
like a receiving authority right so
being penetrated but then also
accepting uh the strange at the same
time so it's like authority which
imposes
the foreign or the strange and that's
that's what's going on it's kind of it's
it has to do somewhat with the kind of
666 symbolism that i've talked about i'm
not saying that it's the mark of the
beast i don't think it is but it has to
do with that it it's a it's a part of
this pattern that is kind of
kind of appearing so so don't go around
saying i said it was the it was the mark
i don't i actually don't think that you
know
uh but i do think that it is showing us
how this works and helping us see that
it's
that that these types of patterns are
right there on our horizon um
yeah okay so
man i can't believe i answered that
question so mark from tblc says
uh i just wanted to share an image that
popped out of a dream my wife had a few
weeks ago it made my jaw drop in my
dream a cow swallowed a wolf
have you come across this image before
for me it's an image of the domestic
devouring nature or authority devouring
liberty
our wildness being tamed civilization
devouring our individuality and kid who
tame the fall yeah
uh i mean i don't know the fall but it's
rather it's rather a
an idea of civilization of civilization
taking over right and so you know that's
what i talk about this the kind of beast
system or 666 symbolism that's exactly
what it is right it's the idea of
a tyranny in the name of safety a
tyranny in the name of something which
is not dangerous
and so um
[Music]
so yeah
good call it's like you have a really
you had a really good intuition about
that um all right
so now so a bit not bothered says in the
1990s there was an influx of english
comic book writers to america via
vertigo comics yes
in a documentary about the comic book
2018 neil gaiman said americans trust
heroes the english don't what influences
has neil and other english comic book
writers had on how americans
tell stories in the last 20 years so i
agree i think that the
that the british invasion you know uh
alan moore neil gaiman i always forget
the third guy i forget his name
anyways it doesn't matter
uh that they are really man they on the
one hand i think
they are part of the really manifesting
of the breakdown
and at the same time they're preparing
the world for a new re-enchantment um
one other thing that
that um
characterizes gaiman and alan moore's
work and the other guy forget his name
is the idea
of the archetype
and its idiosyncrasies the archetype
that forgets
who he is or refuses to be who he is
right you see that in
in the season of mists um
series where um
where uh lucifer refuses to be lucifer
you also see it in uh that series i
forget the names of all the series but
it was it was alan moore's superhero
series where it's basically shazam i
forget but it was called something else
uh
where he he wakes up as an adult and he
forgot who he is like he forgot who his
what his power was and so
so it has to do with this kind of weird
we i think and and also uh
neil gaiman did that in the eternals his
eternals comic too where it's like all
these gods that forget who they are you
know
and so um
and you see that in american gods as
well the idea of principalities which
are
just really idiosyncratic which really
are just individuals you know um
and so yeah so it's definitely part of
the breakdown but there is something in
there in their writing which is
preparing a kind of re-enchantment you
know also because alan moore was an
occult is an occultist and there's a lot
of oto and magic stuff in his
in his comics um
and i think that despite himself i think
is um
yeah i think despite himself despite
themselves they will
be seen as having participated in the
re-enchantment
as it happens
so yeah there's a video on the clip
channels where i where i kind of give my
criticism of neil gaiman
as well
all right so arosa 77 can you comment on
critical theory
which of its insights are beneficial how
can some of its theories be symbolically
understood and what are its deficiencies
i mean i'm obviously not
a big fan of
critical theory i mean it's basically a
form of cultural
the word the words you can't use it's
cultural marxism that's what critical
theory is it's a it's applying uh
marxist notions of materialism
and um and revolution to
to meaning and to cultural forms that's
really what they were doing and so i'm
actually
james lindsay promised that he would
come on the channel but he's just he
said he's just been busy and been
traveling so maybe one day we'll have
james lindsay on the channel and we can
kind of talk about that directly you
know i think that they are
one of the things which which uh
let's say
which
is important in critical theory and
post-modern a lot of post-modern
theorists as well
is that in their thinking there's
something like a
re-injection of symbolism and you see it
in
a lot of the a lot of the post-modern
kind of messy crazy theory theories and
the imagery they use
is often very coherent
it's very coherent but it's upside down
and so
the way that they understand masculinity
and femininity is often actually quite
accurate it's just that they hate
the masculine and so they try to use
let's say feminine imagery and and
imagery is of the strange the stranger
you know the the um all of this type of
imagery to subvert and so
it's but in that move is is already a
re-enchantment and so like i said
there's a there's a way in which all of
this will
at some point start to turn
and uh i think we see inklings of it
already
at least that's my
so if you want to know like the the this
god's dog book that mature and i wrote
it's part of it's partly that one of the
reasons why we're putting it out on
halloween one of the reasons why it's it
some of it looks weird because it's a
monster with a halo there's all this
kind of flavor to it it's because we're
actually going what we want to do what
we wanted to do in that story is to
to flip it back flip the script back to
present a story which has
all the first glance on the first
glimpse of being kind of subversive and
weird and disturbing and then and then
surprise people by the way that it turns
out and so and bringing let's say
bringing normality out of the out of the
the monstrous let's say and so you'll
see like there's some things about it
which people i know some people are
gonna feel uneasy about because it's
gonna look weird especially at the
outset but uh hopefully you trust us and
us but trust us enough by now
to know that uh
to know that we've got we've got our own
tricks up our sleeves let's say all
right
all right so pneuma says i feel that
there's sometimes a little
too much shade thrown at jacob when we
talk about him
understandably when he deceives isaac
but he really does it at rebecca's
command and he seems to be hesitant to
do it at all plus esau doesn't appear to
care about his own birthright and sells
and he sells it to jacob scripture even
says he belittled or despised it and
rebecca has a confusing prophecy
about how the older shall serve the
younger also jacob's given the name
israel which is something like an
angelic or heavenly name
so all that to ask what is the
significance of the two names given to
jacob and esau's names
especially since their second ones are
given at turning points
in their lives and so
yeah it's interesting like
man
there's in jacob there's something
there's something really surprising
about about jacob which is that
there really is something about the
trickster and jacob and about
something about also the the second sun
the idea of
how the first son or the first man falls
and then the second son or the second
one is able to to to to get from him so
so esau's name is edom
edom is adam it's just adam it's the
same name
and it means red or it means red you
know red earth or whatever
so esau's second name is just adam it's
really fascinating but you can
understand how adam
it's like it's like kane so it's like
adam kane
uh
esau
and then abel
and jacob
um
so there's something going on there for
sure
and
yeah
yeah there's something about there's
something about how
jacob is able to
to trick i don't know how this it's
jacob is able to trick
not trick but let's say contrive
god into giving him the blessing and i
don't totally it's like one of those
things which is for us it's weird it's
like for us this is it doesn't work like
for us it doesn't work and one of the
reasons why it doesn't work is because
we're most about you people that are
watching this we're we're edom we're
esau
we are we are we are rome
right
we are the
and so we have our faults right we're
the ones who tried to kill her we tried
to kill our brother we're the ones who
who abuse our brother
jacob
uh we are and it's and it's horrible
that that's the case but
there is something about
at least there's something about being
rome and being esau which makes it hard
for us
to understand
the nature or the reason for
for the trick or for the idea of
contriving somehow in this strange sense
uh so sorry like it's what i'm saying
seems even more cryptic than what the
question it's like i'm not helping you
understand it but i'm giving you some
some hints and some path to think about
this
um
yeah
all right so patrick blonsky says
in the story of the last supper christ
reveals who the traitor is and he
answered
and said he that dippeth his hand with
me in the dish
the same shall betray me but it seems
like the apostles didn't hear him
because you would think they would be
looking out for that and even pursue
judas after seeing him
so
you also have to kind of understand that
the apostles really didn't know what was
going on
you know and so
it's understandable just in terms of
storytelling because it's like here's
christ and he just washed their feet
right and he just gave them he just gave
them
uh communion he just gave them his body
and blood and now he's saying
this one is gonna betray me and so i
don't think people i don't think that
the
disciples were able to even understand
what was happening it was just too much
so i think that this is this is why
christ tells him
uh you know and you have to kind of
understand that also that the fact that
they're dipping their hand in the same
dish
that they they both have you could say
they both they're sharing a secret
right and the secret is that judas knows
what he's going to do
and christ knows what he's going to do
and as they dip their hand in the same
bowl they basically are sharing a secret
from the two opposite sides
um you know and so
and so christ tells them to you know
it's like i know what you're going to do
just go ahead and do it
to show him that he's in on the secret
and so
so i think that that's what's going on
there
all right so curiouser and curiouser
ask why does it say in revelation that
the leads of the tree of life are for
the healing of the nations thanks
jonathan um
i think i mean there are a few ways to
understand this one is to understand
that
the the obviously the leaves are like
the outgrowth of the tree they are the
the final things and we also use
leaves um
you know to make medicine but obviously
we can use other things to make medicine
as well but
the idea is it's the outgrow so it's
like the the
the edges of the tree the the end of the
the place where it stops
right then that's where the medicine is
and that's where you can heal the
nations and so i've always kind of
understood it also as a way
to
to um
compensate
for the the fig tree and so right so
adam and eve fall and they take the
leaves of the fig tree and they tried to
heal themselves right they tried to
cover themselves with the fig tree
in order to
right in order to cover their fall in
order to cover their shame and so i see
this as kind of a
as a trope saying that basically it
undoes or it's the right the right
application of this pattern where the
tree the leaves of the tree are for the
healing
of of the nations
in the final story and also the
the
these things meant to cover right they
also are there to uh to heal so
yeah i hope that makes sense
i feel like i don't know why do i feel
like maybe it's because i'm drinking
beer i don't know what i feel like the
answers i'm giving are like making it
more cryptic and not helping you
understand at all uh
and so hopefully when i don't think a
lot of clips are going to come out of
this q a like all these cryptic answers
i'm giving you all right so um so nico
says why does the bride wear white and
the bridegroom black
and what should they wear
um
this is really just my intuition you
know i don't think that the idea of the
bridegroom wearing black is a super old
tradition it's i don't think it's very
old but nonetheless i don't think i
think there's some kind of meaning to it
you know i think that
the bride wearing white obviously has to
do with virginity and purity
um and the bridegroom weary black i
think has to do with sacrifice i think
it has to do
with um with a form of dying
he had that he has to die to himself in
order to become a husband
that's the way that i i see that but you
know that's just my intuition i might be
wrong for sure the ride wearing white as
being pure that's something which is
pretty obvious but the bridegroom
wearing black
is maybe a little more cryptic but i
would think that's probably what it is
for the same reason why a priest wears
black for the same reason why
yeah
why johnny cash were black you know it's
like an idea of a kind of a kind of
dying to yourself a kind of uh yeah
giving giving so giving yourself as a
bride and giving yourself as a
bridegroom is not the
same all right so
all right so now we're done with the
website we're moving on to subscribe
star only two questions on subscribe
star i just want to warn you too if you
put in your question uh late today it
won't be part of the q a so you have to
try to get your question in a little bit
before because we need the time
for the moderators to go through the
questions and uh
and kind of sort them out so
all right so little joe asks why is it
that a lot of christians east and west
see the eucharist as just a symbol when
it is truly
when it truly is christ the satanic
worshipers try their best to steal it
for their black masses why do they
believe
more than some of us
i mean the truth is i'm not sure satanic
worshipers
a lot of them who would want to do this
totally believe it
they believe in the sacrilege which is
they believe in insulting what you
believe in that's something that they
care about so they care about taking the
most precious thing
uh the most precious thing that you have
and and uh
and the you know and showing how they
have the power to defame it and to uh
you know
to take your highest thing and treat it
like like nothing and so
so i think that's what's going on with a
lot of satanic worshipers but for sure
like why did they see it just a symbol
when it truly is christ i think that
that is of course a symptom of the
of just the the move into modernism and
the breakdown of
of symbolic thinking as the as the main
the main way in which people understood
things in the ancient world you know
where they didn't see the they didn't
see
meaning and factuality as opposites they
saw them as joined together and they
didn't see
symbolism and reality as being separate
they saw the symbol as making something
real you know and so i think that that's
what's going on there as well
um
so sorry i'm a little confused here
okay so uh also i'm hearing a lot about
orthodox theologian priest uh laura m
geels sorry ask sergey bulgakov uh care
to give us a summary of his thought
influence
um
well
i don't to be honest with you
i don't i don't i don't i don't uh i'm
not a super uh an expert on on these on
these russian
these russian uh thinkers
and so
i think the the thing with bulgakov that
is hard is because he's part of a
controversy
and so
it's difficult for me i don't want to
speak on him too much because he's he's
part of us the controversy of
of sociology which is this desire to
kind of express
the the the
feminine in the divine
but and so it's he's controversial
because of that and so he he seems to
want to see
the uh sophia in um
in the old testament as being a uh
as the almost like uh like a
hypostasis of the trinity and so that's
caused a lot of controversy
so i don't want to talk about that too
much sorry i don't like to get into to
to uh theological uh controversy
oh man all right
all right on patreon matthew mold
mulbrandon asks a major problem in times
of political strife is turning into the
thing you are railing against
i think in the in the us this is
particular problem from pc becoming
everything they purport to dislike
to the people storming the capital to
save democracy do you also see this
decline as a major issue in particular
what are one of the two stories from the
bible or other traditions that
illustrate this issue
do they offer any solutions
and
or do you have any words of wisdom
and so
hmm
yeah i think so i think that
an interesting
an interesting version of this right is
in king saul king saul
seems to be all about that
um
and so king saul
i mean
i don't know if it's really that people
become to become what they hate it's
just that every
side of a of an opposite if taken to be
the only truth will
not be able to perceive the world
correctly
and will tend to
embody excess
and will tend to become tyrannical in
its in its in
its implications will tend to become
tyrannical in the way that it manifests
itself and so i think that that's what's
going on and so
people never see their own tyranny they
just see it as
the importance of what they believe in
and so it's like if you think something
is super important then you won't
you won't flinch at the ways and the
methods that you use to impose them you
can see that with covet as well right
it's like
people
have decided that being safe from this
disease is the highest value and so
everything goes like everything is
willing to happen and so they're not
able to see
the tyranny of their
of their actions you know and i think
that that's
that's what's going on um
and there is in a way a manner in which
extremes kind of meet or extremes look
like each other you know
and what they look the way they look
like each other is by becoming
authoritarian you know
and so you can have an
but you can have different kinds of
authoritarianism
so that's what i see and king saul what
i meant by king saul is king saul is
interesting because he he always goes in
excess right so he
he tries to do something right but he
goes too far and then it becomes weird
you know and so
the the great example is when he decides
he's gonna fast
you know for god in order before he
fights a battle and he's well that
sounds great right he's gonna fast and
he's going to so he orders all his
soldiers to fast before a battle which
is like first of all pretty intense you
know have you you're gonna
fast before you eat but then he goes
even further he says something like
anybody who eats before the battle is
going to be killed i'm going to kill him
if he eats anything you know and so uh
you see
his son jonathan eat some honey and so
all of a sudden it's like okay they're
gonna kill your own son
you know because of this thing that you
said um but then you see that
that uh king saul
also at some point tries to be flexible
and not listen to the law like god says
that he has to
yeah this is the place the part of the
bible everybody hates but he says god
says that he has to kill everything
and he doesn't want to do it so he
preserved these animals and these and
and uh
and so
that's how god reproves him but then he
tries to be too strict
to to do something super spiritual
um but then he goes too far and so
it seems to me like that's something of
an example uh of that
um all right
all right so drew mcmahon asks
all right can i ask about the
procedure everybody's asking about that
so that's fine i understand why you're
asking about that
so he said in in my digging into this
covid procedure i stumbled i'm changing
the words by the way i don't want to see
the word because you know i stumbled
upon an inconvenient fact that many of
the modern
vaccines we are taking have used aborted
fetal cell lines in their development
how can a christian take any vaccine
that use such
technique
um
and so i would say that it is definitely
an issue it's definitely a problem
um
but
this is um
what i'm going to say is is i'm going to
say what i'm going to say is going to be
harsh but you have to if you're going to
go down that line
if you're going to go down the moral
line
then you have to be aware of what it
implies which is that
any technology that i use
if this technology was acquired or
developed through immoral means
that makes this technology invalid and
so
you just have to be if you're really
willing to go down that line you have to
be careful
because you can't just apply to this one
vaccine now
you have to understand that in your cell
phone
in your cell phone you have you have uh
medals you have super conductors
that are
that are taken out of the hands of
enslaved children
that are working in mines in congo
you know you have to know that a lot of
the medical developments were developed
by the japanese and the germans during
world war ii by experimenting on
prisoners
um you have to understand that a lot of
the
and so i would say
just be careful and so i i i'm not
wanting to diminish what's going on i
think that it is a very disturbing thing
that we see and it's very disturbing for
example
that the governments are now trying to
prevent people from giving a religious
um
uh
you know uh religious opposition to to
to the vaccine
so
but i would say just be careful not to
judge others just be careful not to look
at other people and say how can you be a
christian and do this
because if you do that it implies
it implies a lot of things for yourself
as well
um so
that's what i think about that but i
don't think i think it is a big deal and
i think that in terms of meaning
the fact that there's aborted fetal
cells related to this
you know the word uh in hebrew for uh
for a uh stillbirth or an aborted fetus
is is a nephal which is the word we use
in nephilim that is the fallen ones and
so
that's uh
yeah that's something to think about
there's a relationship between monsters
and uh and aborted
fetuses or um are stillbirths
because they're ill they're misformed um
or not fully formed beings
all right so white lawrence asks of all
the icons you've ever carried which one
or ones are you most satisfied with and
so i think for sure the one i did for
jordan peterson because we just put
spent so much time and effort developing
it you know it's an icon of saint
michael killing the dragon which has all
these inserts of stone
um and um and using kind of uh
these um
this basma which like a metallic
background and everything so i'm really
excited a frame by andrew gould i'm
really happy with that i just find it's
probably one of the top icons i've made
but there's another one also there's an
icon of saint anthony which i carved
which is a very simple icon but there's
something about the face that i did
which i felt was very um
vivid and uh
and uh and well and just well done it
just has something about it when i look
at it i like to look at it it
i feel like i captured something so
that's another one
all right and so
so reuben korff asks i've been having a
little difficulty
understanding some of the miraculous
healings of christ namely
these are the healings of mark 7 etc
where
christ uses saliva to heal blindness and
muteness
i can't shake the temptation to think
that these acts
as parody of the symbolic structure of
existence are using the water from above
to heal rather than reveal them properly
could you help with understanding this
phenomena and so you're right you how
you're completely right it has to do
with waters from above
uh water from the garden that is that is
used to
to heal
uh but i don't know why do you see it as
a parody
i'm not sure i don't see why it's a
parody and it's also even like the the
the um
the the time when christ heals the blind
person spits
in the
in the in the dust and then makes like a
paste and then puts it on his eyes it's
like that's a very powerful image of um
of like a new creation right something
from above coming down now it's not the
the breath but it's the waters from
above which mix with this dirt and then
it kind of restores creation or brings
about a new creation
so no i think you're right i think your
intuition is right but just because we
don't like spit and we're we're we find
it uh disturbing
is uh to me that that doesn't does
doesn't mean anything for the story you
know there are a lot of traditions where
you spit on things to bless them i don't
know if you saw my big fat greek wedding
you see that in that in that uh movie
where as the bride and groom are walking
down
you know are walking through the church
then people in the aisles are spitting
on them and you think what the heck is
going on and it has to do with the idea
that it's fitting as a form of blessing
so sending water from above
uh down
is a form of blessing just like that you
have rain as a blessing yeah you know
so yeah
so christopher kant says hello jonathan
there's a trope and storytelling where a
woman would dress herself to appear as a
man in order to surpass patriarchal
boundaries and prove herself in battle
alongside the men an example of this
lies in stories like lord of the rings
with eowyn and in mulan
is there any deeper meaning to the
subversion that surpasses the shallow
version shown in modern media i know the
jar token was the support of the
traditional patriarchy which is why the
trope stuck out to me and so
oh mercy all right and so um
there's a few things going on in this
so on the one hand there is of course
the idea of
the amazon and so this is not what
you're talking about and a lot of the
stuff we're seeing today is the amazon
so it has to do with
with these kind of monstrous women
that are on the edge of the world that
kind of come in and are super powerful
and overpower men
you know and also don't need men
they are they don't uh
they don't need men to be their their
their spouses they're not married you
know
so that's one
and so the other one like the kind of uh
mulan uh or the story lord of the rings
or
or in joan of arc story
what you see is rather
the feminine wanting to
let's say
ascend the hierarchy
in a way in this kind of hierarchy of of
performance in the male world
in a way that is in service
to
a higher purpose
and not to
the freeing you know of the
of not in a revolut there's no
revolutionary
thing going on it's like in joan of our
story she wants to free the king she
wants to save the king that's that's
what she wants and so she actually
rises up in this hierarchy of of of
excellence of masculine excellence um
but not in a way that is disverted but
rather
to be kind of uh
to be kind of elevated into that
so
but even joan of arc obviously was was
accused of subversion and was
and was kind of dangerous for the system
um but i think that that's what you see
in these types of stories
yeah all right so
chase and lindsay asked hey jonathan i
noticed recently that i can't find a
single example of a time travel story
about people going into the past to
alter future events that was written
before the modern age i have found
medieval and ancient stories of the
opposite where someone travels into the
future but not a single example of going
into the past or change or attempt to
change events is there a reason why
these stories don't seem to exist before
the 1600s or if they did exist
why they died out and have been lost um
so
i think one of it is one of it has to do
with materialism you know
it's like
because you can travel to the past
it's called reading a book for goodness
sake i mean
you can travel in the past it means
listening to the traditions that are
handed to you by your
ancestors by knowing the old stories the
old songs in that way you are traveling
into the past
uh
but because we're materialists we have
the idea of like physically going back
which doesn't make any sense like it
just
yeah it's going back in the past and
then
uh re-experiencing what was going on
there
um and so in terms of the idea of
traveling into the future you can
understand why you would have older
stories about traveling into the future
because the future hasn't happened yet
and so
you the
so you would have more explicit stories
of traveling into the future instead of
a story of someone who just reads a book
because
there's a sense in which that causality
hasn't manifested so it's like
yeah moving into the future and so and
often these stories have something to do
obviously in those stories that people
can't go back
right they can't go back in the past
it's not like you know you have the
story of the uh the hurley thingy for
example with these kings that
the the king that goes out into the elf
world or the dwarf world and then when
he comes back it's like 300 years later
but he can't go back to his old time
it's like it's over right he's he's just
traveled into the future you have
stories like the seven sleepers of a
thesis where people fall asleep and then
wake up so many years later
uh that kind of stuff and so
yeah so those are so so i think it's
just it's just it's just materialism
people
don't see it as meaning they just see it
as
yeah
all right
so annie crawford asks i've heard you
say that this modern era of dualism
inaugurated by nominalism was inevitable
or part of the pattern itself can you
explain this a bit more why did the
medieval synthesis have to fall apart if
it is fundamentally true is this because
the cosmos after the fall like the human
person must undergo decay
and death before it is born anew
so it has to do with that um
and it also has to do with this with a
weird mystery about the incarnation
which is that
the incarnation leads to death
and
that in dying there's a
covering or
filling up
and so there's a way in which
i don't want to say nominalism is good i
don't think nominalism is good i don't
think that these modern
tropes
uh are good even some like colonialism i
don't think is good even something like
all of these modern tropes which which
came out of nominalism and these these
uh intellectual moves
um they nonetheless fill the world
the breakdown fills the world and so
there's even something going on now
which is that in the secularism
there's a sense in which
in which that breakdown also fills up
the world
you know a good very simple example
i gave that today actually to jp maxwell
in our french podcast this example which
is that
you know in english right before we used
to say
to mark time we used to say a.d you know
before
we say bc you know for like before
christ and then a.d for ano
anno domini which is the year from the
year of the year in the year of our lord
um and so you know it's like a very
christian way of telling time and now
the moderns they're embarrassed by that
they don't like that they don't like the
direct relation
the direct uh connotation of christ and
so they want to break it they want to
destroy it they want to break it apart
and so they change the term they say
b c e and c e which is the common era
and so so they try to remove christ by
saying common era
and it's just fascinating because
they're actually making that the the
idea that christ's birth
is the fundamental change in reality
they're either hammering that in by
removing him by saying that the birth of
christ or the life of christ inaugurated
a common era in which all people can
agree on how to tell dates
is doing the opposite of what they think
they're doing
and so i think that that's the mystery
of this of this breakdown there's an
there's a way in which even in the
secularism it's actually revealing the
manner in which christianity has
completely imbibed our thinking
completely by our social our social
patterns
um
and so
yeah
so i think it is part of the story
but it doesn't excuse it it doesn't uh
i'm not justifying what happened
so hi jonathan what is the symbolism of
blowing candles on a birthday cake it is
probably has some pagan roots but i
guess there's some deeper meaning given
that it's stuck around
i mean
i always thought that it just meant
you're you're blowing out those years so
right you put as many candles as years
as you you've been alive and then you
then you you blow them out because
they're gone you're right you're that
closer to death
[Laughter]
sorry for the inappropriate laugh
uh
so uh so yeah so you know i think that's
what it is i mean it's basically it's
basically
uh blowing the
blowing those lives
out you know um
and it
there's something else going on there
there's something also about the cake
about about about eating this cake and
so it's like we're eating we're
the candles are there to represent the
number of years you've been alive and
then you blow them out
um and then it becomes food for all the
people that are there it's a really
actual pretty powerful symbolism
yeah it's pretty powerful in that sense
i have to think about why it why
makes it why you can have a wish though
so why is it that you can wish when you
blow out the candle so you blow up the
candles
then you offer your the body of that
life to all the people that are gathered
you know you can you gather them into
yourself by giving
giving them like your your life
basically um
and then you have a wish so i guess
there's something about
looking up and then
yeah i'd have to think about the wish
thing
all right so dorothea says what do you
think about the claim that we live in an
inverted society that rewards extrovert
an extroverted society sorry that
rewards extrovert behavior and rejects
introversion there's something in
scripture or the tradition akin to the
notion of extroversion introversion
um i don't know i never thought about
that
but you're right it definitely does a
reward extroversion and i think that
that has to do with the idea that we
live in a world of of science and
materialism and things you can you can
look at and calculate and you can
describe you know rather than things
that are happening in the secret and
things that are
happening
without being seen you know it has to do
also also with um
social media culture and
reality
reality tv you know the idea that if
something does isn't on tv if something
hasn't been filmed if something
isn't in the media then it hasn't
happened or that it barely happened
um and this is the very opposite of of a
more traditional way of understanding
which is that the secret transformations
in your heart those are the most real
and everything else should be fruit of
that
but we can't
rely
on outer
works and on outer
sides
to really
understand the the the deeper part or
the the hidden part
yeah i think that i think that um
a traditional societies are are at least
at
different levels they're always somewhat
introverted
you know they tend to keep to their own
let's say
and there's there's also um a general
sense that to be too loud and too
boisterous and to take up too much room
is always a bad sign
whereas we see the opposite which is if
someone is quiet and kind of holds his
own and doesn't uh engage with all these
people then we see that as unhealthy
all right so jan peter jager asked when
people organize themselves for instance
in a company or for an activist cause
they they're
they always start to exist secrets often
secrets that have a certain impurity or
sin involved for example a company tells
a lie to sell more products the same
time in the modern world we long for
transparency especially from people who
have an opposite cause
or work for a rival company
is this normal human dynamics or
particular for the modern world could
you shed light on this topic
and so
i think you're right i think i think
you're right
and
i think there's a
the way to understand it i don't see it
as a modern thing at all i think the way
to understand it is
there's almost like a causality effect
which is that
you have to be careful
when you start something of how you
started that
when you begin something
that if the beginning is properly
balanced and that in the beginning
there's the right
alignment let's say
um then the fruits of that will
show themselves um but that if there is
already a lie let's say in the founding
or in the beginning then
then that will also play itself out all
through the system and so i think that
that's true and i think so i think that
lies that are the further down you are
in the system the less it in a way
matters
uh for the system whether or not there's
a lie there so it's like imagine i don't
know some
some random worker lies it's not good it
can damage it it can infect the the
system or the company but if the
president lies and the vice president
lies and the top organ organizational
people lie
then those ramifications kind of
come down the uh
the hierarchy
uh and will create a toxic like a really
bad situation
so
i can't believe i used the word toxic i
don't think i've ever used that word
ever before
uh see i've been
infiltrated by certain ways of thinking
um
all right so that's good enough for that
i think so isaac malcolm says hi
jonathan don't know if i have an easy
question but i would love to hear
anything you have to say
all right how do you differentiate
between symbolic thinking and poetic
thinking do you think there is one
um
and so
i think they're they're very much
they're the same
they're just just uh
let's say one is bigger than the other
so poetic thinking is ordered thinking
you know it's the idea it's a it's a
hyper emphasis on the fact that language
is ordered it has to be right we've
talked about this so many times you have
to order facts into patterns in order
for them to be communicated but there's
also a way in a type of order
which can also
call attention to itself
in terms of the order itself that is
that they reveal their orderliness and i
think that that's something that you see
in poetic language
and i think that
that's often what happens in symbolism
or things that are highly symbolic we
could say are things in which it's
easier to perceive the order so
everything you do is symbolic right
everything from breathing to
to you know anything
that you're that you can identify as
having existence has a symbolic pattern
to it but there are certain things like
you know let's say religious songs or
liturgy or icons or
sacred spaces or all of these things
that are
more that are heightened
um and i think it's the same with poetry
and so poetry is a heightened
order
that helps you
perceive that it helps you perceive the
order itself
hope that makes sense
all right so dean parker says when we
invent something totally new are we
actualizing a form pattern that already
exists in waiting or allowing a new form
to emerge
my thoughts were that the forms are
persistent and finalized from creation
and anything newly invented is just a
derivative of an already established
form so yes that's right that's what
you've got you can't ever invent
something totally new that is a
completely
incoherent possibility
well okay so let's see it this way you
probably could you could but we're not
totally new but at least let's say on
the border of totally new but actually
the way that if you encountered
something which was totally new
or on the border being totally new
then you would actually encounter it as
a monster
you would encounter it as a monster
first because it would have nowhere to
rest it would have no room no house to
live in so it would appear as this
shifty chaotic identity you know
uh right there's this there's this
idea i don't know if it's true but
there's this idea that the
when the spanish arrived in uh
in central america
the um the people
the they could see the boat they could
and the boats were on the water
right coming for for a very long time
but the people
couldn't see them they just couldn't see
them so the boats were coming but they
couldn't see them because there was they
had nothing to connect it to it was
completely outside of their capacity to
perceive
um
and so at some point they had to because
it became it came so immediate that they
had to see these monsters they had to
encounter these these monstrous beings
and then slowly
tame them and slowly kind of integrate
them into their world
um
and so i think that so i think that uh
that's the way that it happens you know
uh and and obviously i've mentioned this
before there's no value in novelty
um and so you know it's like i think
that this is something for example like
one of the problems that happened to
tesla i think is what is this is that
tesla
at first proposed new things
and it was like woo it was new enough
and it was it was similar enough to the
things that already were there that
people were like yeah let's integrate it
and then he's like propose another thing
that now was so outside of what people
thought was possible and and and another
way of thinking and another way of
playing things that it that it could not
be integrated and it wasn't and uh you
know tesla
died a poor man a poor and miserable man
so i think that that it it's actually a
little example of like
not the totally new but the almost
totally new let's say
sorry jonathan can you please elaborate
on the metaphysics of patterns if i
remember correctly you said that the
pure pattern
don't exist they need bodies but you
also said that the angel of the city
still exists when the city is burned
down
how can we bring these statements
together thank you for your insights
and so the
i mean pure patterns exist in the mind
of god like they they exist
as pure patterns but they
they they exist in the world with bodies
they have to have bodies they don't have
to be physical bodies but they they can
have to have some kind of expression you
know or else they're just
what are they they're just a
pure
pure intuition i guess you know and so
they kind of need to embody themselves
even for you to perceive them or to
to be able to contemplate them or to
talk about them um
so that's what i meant by that and so
the angel of the city exists when the
city is burnt down
it exists in the sense that
i mean it exists eternally
his body is the city
and so angels don't exist the same way
we do right they just don't exist in
time the same way we do that is that the
angel of a city
has a body which is the city of which
it's an angel and then when the ba when
that body is destroyed in our world it's
still it's still it still exists it's
still the body of the city
body of the angel it's
because an angel doesn't exist in linear
time the way that we
tend to think
so to me it doesn't it's not i know it
may be hard for some people to
understand to me it's just it's just not
a problem at all
um
yeah so hopefully that's helpful i don't
know maybe i'm not explaining it well
enough but i i struggle to find another
way to explain this
all right so walrus king 14 says hi
jonathan can you could you explain some
of the symbolism behind making the sign
of the cross specifically
could you go into why the father is
attributed to the head the sun to the
stomach and the holy spirit uh to the
shoulders
um could it have something to do with
the intellect the body and the directing
of will
so i think
i think
this is speculating here i'm totally
speculating
but for sure the idea that the father is
the head that's not complicated that's
really easy
um but i think that when it's not that
the sun is the stomach is that the sun
is the descent
right the sun is descending from the
father it's coming down
into the world
i think that that's why the sun is
is down um
and like the belly is the body you know
you could see it that way if you want
but it's mostly to understand this
descent and then this the
the the holy spirit is more about
connecting right connecting the two
together and so being this
connection between the father and the
son
that's the best you're gonna get from me
i'm sure some people have said more
subtle and uh interesting things about
that
all right so nathan condon asked hello
jonathan what is the best christian
movie you have seen
and what is the worst
the best christian movie you have seen i
don't know are there christian movies
really like
like made by christians like or have
christian stories
you know
i think that like uh
it's weird like i i keep i keep thinking
like
uh something like uh hacksaw ridge is is
a great christian movie it's not a
christian movie really yeah i think
but uh you know even movies like
apocalypto which are which i'm still in
the mel gibson world like okay so mel
gibson makes the best christian movies
maybe
um although the passion i just i didn't
i didn't it wasn't to my to my taste
let's say um
but you know it's hard to it's hard to
to
you know of course you know the some of
the stories of uh some of the moves like
jesus of nazareth is a powerful movie
it's it's well done
compared to some of the other jesus
movies let's say
um
yeah
but i
the worst man it's like there's so many
bad christian movies that say call
themselves christian
like the problem is that i haven't
watched a lot of them a lot of them i
what was that movie fireproof or
whatever i think i watched that one man
just so bad
all right
just just moralism it's just when it
falls into just pure moralism you know
it's just annoying
all right
so and also one of the problems that
every movie that i like is because it
has even though it's not directly
christian
it it it's because it's it's kind of
revealing some aspect of the story of
christ and that's often why i find it
interesting so
yeah it's difficult
someone asked in the chat about the
chosen series ah man
like i hate to say this i'm not a super
big fan of the chosen series a lot of
people like it i get it i understand
there are some things about it that i
like like we watched it with my family
the first season at least you know i
like for example like the personality of
peter i like i kind of like his
personality i think that he kind of got
that
but
i think that it's just so hard to have
someone play christ man
it's so difficult it's like i really
don't my when i read scriptures i don't
see christ as a as a smiley
happy-go-lucky guy i just don't see that
uh
you know i see christ saying some really
harsh things all the time and so
i feel like
that kind of sober image of jesus of
nazareth for example
is more
it's closer to what i see
in christ rather than this kind of
this kind of happy smiley uh jesus
but you know it's like it's hard because
that the christ contains so many
images and so many
all the archetypes are kind of
compressed into him so it's hard because
we all have our little
our little christ which is not the which
is not really the totality of of his
expression so we tend to to be attached
to that so it's like i i yeah
all right okay so
mark kalashnikov uh asked for your last
ethiopia conversation
regarding the notion of the ark what
would it entail for one to be in the ark
and what would that require i don't mean
get on a plane and go to a specific
church to wait it out
more so if you could lay out a few
things to attend to in relation to the
concept of being inside the ark
so thank you for your work
so
one of the aspects of the arc which
people neglect is that the ark people
think of the ark as this like pure thing
which survives the flood but the ark is
not a pure thing it's actually a
complete thing it kind of has everything
in it
and so
i think that a lot of people think that
creating an
arc is going to be something like you
know we're going to we're going to do
this we're going to be the we're going
to be the pure ones right we're going to
be the ones that are that totally follow
the tradition that follow all the the
canons that follow all the rules that
follow all of it uh and like so we're
gonna hold out against the modern world
and i think that that that
that type of approach i think is leading
in part to the breakdown because it's
like an overcompensation for the chaos
so i think that the arc is something
which
is able to
to kind of have it all the whole
hierarchy of being in it in itself and
so
so that's why that's why
i tend to um
to talk about that too like i tend to to
talk about the manner in which
there is the pattern and then there's
also the way the pattern breaks down and
there's the garments of skin and that
this is ultimately all part of the total
pattern
and so so i think that that's
so being inside the ark
um
definitely it has to do with with
being someone who kind of participates
and someone who
is connected to all of this right who
remembers
who remembers god and remembers
scripture and remembers
that which is important um
and then acts in consequence with that
um now it you know does it mean that you
need to connect with other people to a
certain extent yes i think so
now how that that needs to happen
i don't know like do you have to do you
have do you have to go all the way to
forming kind of like communities or
deliberate communities maybe like i'm
not doing that but maybe that's the
the possibility
um
and so i think that that's
that's the best way to understand the
ark
um
it's not the ark is not uh
reactionary
right it it the ark is also something
which is
a kind of positive
cohesion
so
sorry if i'm being vague this whole q a
i'm just being super vague it feels like
man
someone says the left behind films in
the chat it's like i never watched those
i never dared i think i think i
think i can't handle it enough i
couldn't handle the anger that would
come out of me if i watched that series
oh mercy all right so garrett winter
says
hello jonathan very much looking forward
to god's dog i recently came across a
17th century flemish painting by jacob
jordan's called moses and his ethiopian
wife zipporah and his report is depicted
with the head piece that migmicks a
cruciform halo of christ
i don't think have i see i have to find
this
oh whoa
okay wow that's weird
so best case scenario for this painting
is that
it was so far
in uh it was kind of so far in
the breakdown of christian art that they
didn't even they didn't realize that
that's what they were doing it's just a
hat basically
you know
but
if it's
it really looks like a halo
with the cross
man i've never seen that
what a strange
what a strange image
well i have to look into it people have
tried to to think about it that way
all right so nicola alex sick says why
did roman pr
persecute christians with such fervor
what kind of threat did they perceive
from non-conformity
and so
uh it wasn't non-conformity it's that
they wanted rome they wanted christians
to participate in the cult they wanted
christians to worship the emperor and
they wanted christians to participate in
the public cults
because
they believed and they believed rightly
that
if some people didn't participate in the
public cults then the world would fall
apart
right then then the the world would
break down
um
and so
that seems to be one of the reasons you
know one of the other reasons is that
the christians became the
scapegoats you know um for all the
problems especially
starting with the fire right the the
neuronian fire where nero blamed
christians for starting the fire
and so they were the scapegoats
and they also did participate in uh in
kind of in public roman rituals
um so
yeah you know but the thing this is you
could say the secret about the
christians which is that the christians
were
bringing in
a higher form of the pattern and that
the romans weren't able to perceive that
at the outset
but the christians and one of the proofs
that that was the case is that
the christians didn't try to cause a
revolution didn't try to take over
didn't try to um
yeah it didn't try to take over and so
they just were trying to be
you know honest citizens in the roman
empire
except for
the the except for worshipping the
emperor
and so
that's maybe can help you understand the
difference between
let's say
this
new pattern which is arriving on the on
the horizon
um
if it's trying to devour the one that's
in place
explicitly
then then already you have a problem
because it's setting up this
revolutionary pattern which is just
always um
you know
a cycle waiting for another one to come
get it so
all right so norm grenade said in your
recent discussion on the french podcast
with jp marco you discuss peter john
martha mary's example of contemplative
and active
this idea is this idea akin to what
matthew describes as meaning
and matter
uh yes it is akin to that it is akin to
that and so you have the
you have the you have the meaning which
is still and which is
let's say
attentive
and then you have the matter which is
busy and multiple
and embodying you know and so i think
there definitely is a relationship
between that
um
so incidentally why does mary go out to
meet christ in the street after lazarus
dies but martha
is the one at jesus's feet while he
teaches later in the house i think
you're confused about the story
because i don't think martha is at jesus
feet i think it's mary that it is at
jesus's feet
so
unless i miss something from the story
but that's my that's how i remember the
story
all right mar emmanuel montiel ask
i don't know if that's how you pronounce
your name manuel but it just sounded
right did you do you think it's relevant
to look at the old ultimate prophets
specifically isaiah and jeremiah as a
relevant symbolic pattern to what is
occurring in the west i can't help but
notice a stark similarity between the
messages of the prophets and how
applicable it is towards modern western
culture
uh yes i mean i think you're right it's
just hard because it's like you just uh
sometimes i feel like even myself i'm
just too much of a
of a doomsayer all the time and it's
just it's kind of heavy and annoying
so you're right that there seems to be
a need to cry out in the wilderness
right now
but
yeah it's difficult because no one not
only will people not hear you but
they will they might hear you and then
destroy you and you know say you're
you're crazy that you're all the things
people accuse others of today
so stephen bishop says hi jonathan and
icons of the heroing of hades the saints
at christ's right hand usually
saint john the foreigner and the king of
israel are depicted with halos whereas
the saints on his left abel and various
patriarchs are without halos why is this
is this some right left-hand symbolism
so why is john on the right hand of
christ instead of his usual left thank
you so yes i think it is related to that
and i've seen those images i think it's
especially one image or the image in
serbia i'm not sure
um yes i have seen them and i have to be
honest with you that i don't totally get
it either i yes it is this idea it is
the idea of
the right hand with the halos and the
left hand without the halos in the sense
of
the sheep and the goats but i don't
think it's as simple it's obviously not
the sheep and the goats in the sense
that the you know able and the patriarch
and these and the patriarchs are not
goats but there's definitely a desire to
show a distinction between the two um
and so i think that's why saint john is
there on the right is because they want
to have him with a halo
but um
but i'm not sure how they decided which
goes where because they're both in a
certain manner
part of the body
of christ and so
so yeah so i'm not sure
so dan diego de la vega asked hi
jonathan hope you are well when the
practical necessities of the world start
pressing down on you is there any
specific prayer with symbolic
significance that helps you fight
despondency and to keep taking action on
the task you need to do
um
i'm going to be boring but it's just a
jesus prayer to be honest you know it's
just that jesus prayer is the go-to
prayer
to refocus yourself and to um
yeah and to kind of find your center
again
michael mueller asked thoughts on the
star of david from an orthodox
perspective i found the symbol infinite
insightful to understand how the
breakdown is part of a larger pattern
um
and so yeah the star of david the
hexagram which has six points so
is i think it's super insightful there's
a lot of interesting things there
you know it's so it's it's uh it's
two triangles one triangle going up one
triangle going down i think the best way
to understand that is really as a
joining of heaven and earth you know of
a of a womb and a point kind of joining
together a cup and a sword you know uh
like a masculine image and a feminine
image
uh heaven and earth basically
um
as being joined together you know and so
i think that's what it is and so it's so
it's similar it's related to a cross
in that sense right because it's
adjoining of above and below
um
and so
that's how i see it so you can see it as
in a way kind of the six days of
creation with the seventh day as being
the center or the kind of secret the
hidden the hidden meaning
um
so i think that's that's a good way to
understand the the hexagram
all right so janet horseman says what
would be the correct way to understand a
generational curse or sin i listen to
your talk with your mate tom and i
thought the way you explained the
connection between sinful behaviors and
principalities made so much sense
but do these principalities become more
granular like in the case of mental
illness alcoholism substance abuse that
seems to run in the family
if there are more particular
principality over that reality
so
it's not that hard to understand uh
generational
curses or generational sin because your
children are extensions of you
um
and so
they
they kind of carry
not just you but you know of your
ancestors or your line you could say
and so they they kind of manifest those
aspects in the world
you know and that will include the
positive and the negative aspects and
a good way to understand a generational
curse
or sin is to understand that
patterns are more subtle often than we
think
and so
let's say
like the pattern of alcoholism let's say
let's see use that example um
there'll be all these subtle things
around it
which won't necessarily be just the
drinking
um and they'll imbibe
the
the group or invite the family
and so
you know it it could be all kinds of
things they know pattern of alcoholism
could mean that
you know the father's grumpy in the
morning you know it's like he's an
alcoholic he's grumpy in the morning or
he
you know he's
he's distant he's absent and there's all
these things which are there
which make it very difficult because
they kind of imbibe the structure and so
then
let's say the child says something like
i'm not going to be like my father i'm
going to
be against alcohol and i'm not going to
drink you know i'm going to be dry
because my father was an alcoholic
then
they're participating in the pattern
they can't avoid it right because
they're opposing it but they're also
probably imbibing some of the subtler
aspects of that behavior
even though they're not they're not
drinking
and then so then that can fall down
into
into the um the lower
into the next generations and so that's
why sometimes it's
so traditional peoples will
will
maybe sometimes describe it as something
like a form of almost like a form of
reincarnation or a form of cycling of
the souls right some of some jewish
traditions have this idea where it's
like the soul cycle um but you don't
have to understand it in a kind of very
kind of gross uh
you know a kind of gross uh idea of
reincarnation you can understand it more
as like
psychic patterns which fall down onto
the next generation which which
imbibe them with certain behaviors which
lead to other behaviors
and so
it's like i said so you could try to
break the pattern by saying i'm not
going to drink
uh but
even by doing that you're you're you're
ultimately bringing about the
possibility that your child
is going to drink
in reaction to you now or by imbibing
some of the the more secondary patterns
that you are still in that you're still
participating in i don't know if that
makes sense um
[Music]
i think that that's the way to
understand that you know but there's
also a way in which the positive
behaviors are also
uh they also fall back down on your
family and it's it's often in the same
way and almost like in a kind of unsaid
un
you know
an unsaid way that if you act certain
ways and if you are certain ways you
speak certain ways if you treat your
spouse with love and respect then
without telling your kids to do that
they will also
imbibe that you know and so
so you can understand this like you can
understand it in ways that maybe
are
are easier to understand you can maybe
understand it
so
so you can see sometimes something like
the children embodying
the actions or the
subtle patterns of their parents
you know and so
you can find a child that will actually
express
the anger of the spouse
even though the spouse isn't expressing
it will become like a vehicle of their
anger or a vehicle of their resentment
um
and so
never the spouse might not even have
said would never even say to the child
like say bad things about
about their husband or their mother
but
the child will
receive
will notice will mimic patterns and will
see the implications even unconsciously
of what is happening with the dynamic is
uh and then we'll kind of as a fruit
we'll
embody that
and so it's complicated stuff to uh it's
complicated stuff to deal with i think
that you that's why you kind of almost
have to deal with this
as a at a higher level you have to deal
with it at a
at a level which has more to do with you
know going to church together i don't
know what to tell you like just being
together and sitting together and
sharing positive patterns together so
that the negative ones don't take over
man why is it that this entire q a i
feel like i'm just speaking things that
which will give
fodder to
kind of secular atheists to say that i'm
just spouting
gibberish
i'm not
what i'm saying is coherent but i'm not
i'm maybe not expressing it super well
today
all right so harry fisher says hi
jonathan is the lamb slain before the
foundation of the world the only way
there could be something rather than
nothing
is it right to understand the sacrifice
of the sun as the necessary way in which
finite things could come into being out
of the infinite so i think so i really
think so and i think it's very
mysterious and it's something which
is obviously
it's obviously uh
might be controversial to some but i
think like i talked about earlier in the
q a about this idea of the of the
pristine form which has to be pierced
in order
for the world to exist
you know i think that there's something
of that
which is necessary
it doesn't necessarily have to be the
cross it could be something more
subtle you could see it like something
uh like um
the divine logos eternally gives himself
up to the father and then gives himself
for creation and it doesn't necessarily
have to
involve
you know uh putting to death like we see
on the cross although although that's a
legitimate version of that pattern
um it can have a
higher expression let's say
i don't know if it's higher or maybe
a different one
all right so amy says we are commanded
to be obedient to our our authorities
but if the system
coming does end up looking
like the
looking dark mark of the beast would
taking the procedure be a qualitatively
higher and greater participation in that
pattern than any other time we sin and
choose a worldly good over obedience to
god
and so
so it's very simple like i i think i
think it's important that i'm clear
about this like the mark
of the beast the way that it's presented
in scripture
is that it is a form of apostasy
that is that there's something about
receiving the mark which includes
an apostasy which includes a form of
of turning away
explicitly turning away from god it's
not accidental it's not like you could
have taken you could have taken the mark
of the beats without knowing and then
you find out that you took it you know
whatever
um
and so that's important and right now
that's not there then it's not there at
all
i mean not at all it's it's you can feel
it moving towards that
but it's not there yet
and so
like i said one of the dangers one of
the
one of the manifestation which is
closest to to this is the idea of having
to have a passport a sanitary passport
in order to go to church that i think is
the closest thing to to to coming right
up to that symbolism because
uh then it's about it's about a
hierarchy of
of
of priorities right where it's like the
state is now
the
the gatekeeper of religion but it's no
different than peter the great or you
know making the church a bunch of
a bunch of state workers making them
into into state uh you know
civil servants or whatever and the same
with what happened in europe in the
especially in the protestant countries
so
all that is part of the symbolism you
know
all right and so
james cortez says are you familiar with
alexander dugan
i've just been exploring his work seems
uh
seems to be lots of fruitful ideas to
explore and so
you know
i think that for sure dugan has good
insights especially insight into the
breakdown insight into what's happening
in the world
i think that my difficulty with dugan is
the same difficulty i have with
julius evola which is
instrumentalization of religion which is
basically
seeing religion as a tool
to bring back a form of government and a
form of state and uh
as you if you watch my videos you know
that i don't think that
the way in which the religious lays
itself out and how that affects the
state and the way the state will lay
itself out i think those aren't
completely unrelated um but
all the times when the church has become
just a tool of political
ideology
uh
things go completely haywire and go off
the
and so so no i'm not as i'm not a big
fan of dugan because of those reasons
uh jason gadawalt says what are the 14
trees
book of enoch chapter 3 observancy how
in the winter all the trees seem as
though they had withered and shed all
their leaves except 14 trees which does
not lose their foliage but
retain old foliage
from two to three years till the new
comes
um
i don't know why 14. two times seven i
guess
and so two years two weeks two years
so the idea of uh
of a pattern which um
which persists as the other patterns
fall apart like a kind of
a pattern which is more more
is stronger than the others
so
i think that's what it seems to be you
know just just patterns that last longer
you know and so as the others kind of
fall apart it holds the world together
for longer so and maybe it's 14 because
it's like two weeks like the idea that
it's not just one cycle it contains more
than one usual cycle
um
so jeff dunlop says it's a roughly
finished cabin a masculine structure as
i've always thought or is it actually a
feminine structure that invites the
masculine uh
yeah i think it's mostly that i think
it's mostly that you know it's uh it's
um
you know in a way the the men men are
attracted to
the wild
because
they're attracted to um
you know just like
just like uh men like to ride horses
right they're attracted to potential you
know they're attracted to cars that
make that are that have a lot of power
you know that have a lot of uh whereas
women
are
are
almost like attracted to the opposite of
that which is
meaning you know which is ahead which is
something which
um
which shows which shows the structure
right and so that's what they're
attracted to um that's why i see it i
don't know
so matthew f what is the symbolism of
the healing power of peter's shadow in
acts 5.
yeah that's a really interesting uh
interesting story
i have to think about it i have to think
about it
something about death turn against death
i guess but you know that's easy to say
i've never thought about that
so
the wakeful ass dear jonathan can you
speak a little on the symbolic
difference between exclusion and the
marginal
and so
wakeful they're the same thing
and this is where
this is actually where my my
postmodernism is still alive or where de
da is still kind of alive in me
uh is that
there's no such thing as total exclusion
that is anything which can be named is
within the margin of the identity
anything which can be recognized so
complete exclusion
means that it's no no longer even rec
you can't see it you can't recognize it
it's actually not it doesn't have
any
any
hook
onto the system
because even excluding
you exclude in relationship to something
so exclusion is always in relation so
even the outside of an identity is
related to the identity it has to be
that's why we won't say that
the the
i don't know like i i don't know how
else to say it right and so
as soon as something is seen as excluded
from something else it's still connected
to it it has to be because it's excluded
from that
it's not excluded from something else
it's excluded from this identity and so
it it is in a bigger sense it's still
within
the identity
it's still within it's still affected or
connected to the being which excludes it
so and so it appears as margin it
appears as scapegoat it appears as
monster it appears as
you know
all right so marcus david said what are
your thoughts on nft art would you
consider offering your artwork as nfts
and so um
and so uh i mean yeah i told you that i
might be doing god's dog as a
as as nfts
but i'm not sure yet like i'm still
figuring this stuff out i'm still seeing
how it works
um
and uh and so there's also neil degrade
of uh dear paul robbins wrote me today
and said we should do a nft project
together which could be cool to do that
with him just for fun um but for sure if
i do an nft for the comic book i want to
make sure
that it's not just a gimmick like i
would like to
to create a sense of
added value
you know of of added value to the to the
property you know it's instead of um
instead of just rarity for rarity's sake
and so i that's why i have this idea of
creating rarity
with certain ciphers or certain
code certain keys to some of the
symbolism which is which is layered in
god's dog so in when you read god's dog
when you end up reading the comic you
can read it straight through in like an
hour or whatever it's not doesn't take
long to read it if you just read it
through and you you'll get the story and
it'll be totally fine and it'll be an
entertaining story and it'll have
interesting characters and it'll have
character arcs and all that stuff that
you find stories but there's all these
things going on in the background even
in the images that
will be it won't be uh let's say
visible to a lot of people at the outset
and also continue on in the other
stories and so the idea would be
for those people that are willing to
kind of dive into the nft world we would
offer
uh keys
to
this these symbols these symbols and
once they have the keys then they can do
what they want with them they can they
can keep them for themselves or they can
share them with others they can maybe
they won't even understand the keys they
might have to ask other people to help
them decode the even the hints um so
that's kind of what we want to do to
create a more participative treasure
hunt feeling with the nfts so anyways
we'll see i don't know if we're going to
do it it's a plan it's an idea if you
like that make sure to
to tell me
so that i know it's worth the effort
because it's gonna it takes quite a bit
of effort to plan this stuff out and so
uh so yeah all right
so chandler turner said i had the great
pleasure of attending a concert recently
and regardless of kobet it took no time
at all for mosh pit to form a curious
phenomena
and i have seen people walk out of them
with broken fingers black eyes and the
like yet when you ask people this is
often what they enjoy
most about going to show so my question
is
for you is what is the symbolism of the
mosh pit i mean it's the symbolism of
fighting
but it's just a it's like a toned-down
version of fighting it's a it's a
toned-down version of uh of uh or not
tone down but it's similar to rough and
tumble when you're fighting with your
brothers or your cousins when you were
young you know it's kind of
experimenting with the limit
experimenting with your own strength
your own capacity to
to uh to absorb danger to come in
contact with danger to um
you know so i think that that's what's
going on in the in mosh pits um
so yeah
um
all right so
i think
in theory the other questions either
they didn't make it on time
or they've been kind of put aside
um
all right so let me go through one or
two it's ten like i'll give you another
five five
another five minutes i was hoping to
make these like two hours tops now
um so all right so divided differences
says hello jonathan i followed you for a
while now have you gone to incorporate
some of the symbolic patterns you've
described into my creative writing
people i trust have commented that some
of my writing and the form of the
stories seem cliche in a sense it
doesn't bother me since i want to tell
stories about truthful patterns however
i want to strike a balance between
authenticity and instantiating the
pattern
which have affected me very deeply if
the comparison fits between iconography
and writing where do you draw the line
between authenticity and relating
patterns
and so
i think that if you if you if you truly
kind of are able to embody the pattern
then you're able to
have intuitions about their
their depth
then it's not going to come out so much
as a cliche for most people
and so
cliches are often when people just use
tropes
and not to completely understand their
implications
and so that's i think what happens when
cliche so it's almost like a it's like a
pattern but a very superficial one
so i think that's it it's just to really
kind of uh and i would also like i've
told people be careful when you're
writing
not to
uh not to think about symbolism while
you're writing you should you should
kind of write intuitively and then go
back and then edit with symbolic
thinking in order to kind of hone things
and rearrange them reorder them so that
they they're they're closer to
to the patterns um but i think it's
better not to to think about symbolism
because you'll
usually you'll just be
frozen you'll just freeze because
um
all right so let's see let's see um
see last one let's see which one we do
all right so let's try this one cormac
jones ask in the navigation of saint
brendan
there's a part where saint brendan and
crew come up on an island with a tree
that is completely covered with birds
saint brendan asks god what the deal is
with all these birds so one of the birds
flies over and tells them they are
fallen spirits casualties of the fall of
lucider lucifer they say they did not
consent to their demise on account of
which god preserves them from pain but
they are cut off from the faithful
spirits and forced to roam the earth
annually at pasca they are allowed to
gather and praise god saying brendan
spends the paschal period singing and
worshiping god with the birds
is there a right and wrong way to
understand such a story man they gotta
love hagiography they dare things that
you know
are kind of on the on the edge i mean so
the thing you can get out of this is to
understand that
that ancient people and that
in terms of structure that birds are
related to angels that there's a
relationship between birds and heavenly
patterns you could say
um
and so you could understand so the idea
would be that if when the angels fall
they they you know they because they're
not so bad like if they were really bad
they would have fallen into snakes and
and pigs right like christ uh puts them
into pigs and sends them into the deep
but because they're not so bad
they're like the jinn like this is
actually maybe a good example of the
jinn because i've i've asked father
stephen
uh
the young from ad lord of spirits you
know whether or not there's there's a
notion in christianity of jinns which
are these intermediary beings that are
kind of fallen but not so much or in
neutral or not so much this actually
seems to be to be um
at least supporting my theory that this
is a this kind of has to be a part of
the of the structure um
and so yeah i think that that's probably
the way to understand it there are some
patterns which seem
to
not be totally evil but also
seem to kind of be in between or neutral
or yeah so
that's why i would understand that
um
and so
i think we're done because it's 10 and
so look i know some people will have
been disappointed that i didn't get to
your question but it was just becoming
too
unwieldy for me and so i hope you can
understand um
that i that i kind of have to do it this
way and so this now so now it has for
the patreon this has become a
competition so i didn't mean it that way
but yeah in the sense that right concise
questions interesting questions things
that i
haven't uh haven't said before
and so um and so yeah so so go for it
and so i'm looking forward to uh to next
month please if you can think about it
you know sign up for uh god's dog
on indiegogo you can go to godsdog.com
to find the it points to the preview of
the crowdfunding sign up for the
newsletter on october 31st on halloween
itself we launch
and we're really hoping to send a
message with this to send a sign that
that that we are the future i mean not
me or but i mean in the sense that the
world is being re-enchanted
uh and we need to to put our stake down
to stake into that re-enchantment we
need to open up
for the possibility of telling different
kinds of stories and so hopefully this
will be my little my little uh launch
you know and matsir's little
participation and chord and philip karde
who made the um
the uh the colors like it'll be our
little
contribution to trying to bring about a
new type of storytelling so thanks
everybody for your attention
and uh yeah i will see you very soon